O
DUMP A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
INTO A CAMPAIGN TO DEFEAT THAT
MEASURE.
CANDACE OWENS JOINS US TO
UNRAVEL THIS MYSTERY.
GEORGE SOROS DOES NOT LIVE IN
AUSTIN, TEXAS.
I KNOW THAT HE EVER HAS.
HE'S NOT FROM THIS COUNTRY
ORIGINALLY.
WHY WOULD HE WANT AUSTIN, TEXAS,
TO HAVE FEWER POLICE OFFICERS ON
THE STREET?
>> THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
I'M SO TIRED OF THE LEFT
PRETENDING THAT WE ARE PICKING
GEORGE SOROS TO BE OUR BOGEYMAN.
EVERY TIME THIS MAN SPENDS
MONEY, AND STORED IN AN EFFORT
THAT'S GOING TO UNDO AMERICAN
CIVILIZATION.
HE FUNDED BLACK LIVES MATTER,
THE PROTESTS AND RIOTS.
HE'S A BILLIONAIRE.
IF YOU WANTED TO HELP BLACK
PEOPLE HE DOESN'T NEED TO GIVE
TO BLACK LIVES MATTER.
HE CAN GIVE A 10 TONS OF OTHER
CAUSES THAT DO WORK TO HELP
PEOPLE.
BUT HERE WE HAVE THEM AGAIN THE
SAME TYPE OF INITIATIVES GOING
AGAINST POLICE OFFICERS.
IF I AM GOING TO FATHOM AN IDEA
AS TO WHY HE'S DOING THIS,
GEORGE SOROS IS A MAN THAT MADE
HIS MONEY IN INVESTMENTS.
WHAT IS HE DOING?
WHAT IS HE INVESTED IN THAT HIS
INVESTMENTS WOULD GO LONG?
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE HE IS GOING LONG ON CHINA.
WHY WOULD HE BENEFIT FROM AN
AMERICA THAT DOESN'T REALLY
EXIST.
I WANT TO SAY AGAIN I THINK WITH
THE LEFT IS AFTER IS THE
FEDERALIZATION OF THE POLICE
FORCE.
I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THE AMERICAN STORY IS THE SAME
STORY OF EVERY COUNTRY THAT'S
CONVERTED FROM A CAPITALIST
THRIVING SOCIETY INTO A
SOCIALIST SOCIETY.
IT'S THE ONLY THING THAT MAKES
SENSE.
THE QUESTION, WHY DOES
GEORGE SOROS WANT TO SEE THAT?
WHY DOES GEORGE SOROS WANT TO
SEE THE COLLAPSE OF AMERICA.
HAS TO BE INVESTED IN THE
COUNTRY THAT ISN'T AMERICA.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD HYPOTHESIS.
I THINK THERE IS HATE AT THE
CORE OF THIS.
WHY WOULD YOU SYSTEMATICALLY GO
TO CITIES YOU'VE NEVER LIVED IN
AND MAKE THEM MORE DANGEROUS.
IT'S GOING TO RESULT IN MORE
MURDERERS.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED BUT YOU DO
IT ANYWAY.
YOU CLEARLY ARE ANGRY AT THE
COUNTRY.
>> YEAH, OR YOU'RE JUST A PERSON
THAT WANTS TO MAKE MONEY.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE MONEY IS THE
ROOT OF ALL EVIL AND I THINK
THAT GEORGE SOROS' PERSONAL
CARES PASSIONATELY ABOUT MONEY I
THINK HE CARES ABOUT BECOMING
SUCCESSFUL.
I THINK HATE IS ENOUGH TO DRIVE
GEORGE SOROS.
OF COURSE THE CORE OF THIS IS
ALWAYS HATE.
YOU HAVE TO HATE AMERICA.
HATE AMERICAN SOCIETY WERE NOT
CARE OF OUR PAID THE PEOPLE
SUFFERING THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
AUSTIN.
THEY WANT THINGS TO GET SO BAD
IN AUSTIN.
SO BAD IN NEW YORK AND CHICAGO
THAT LIKE LORI LIGHTFOOT IS
CALLING FOR IN CHICAGO, WE NEED
HELP.
SENDING REINFORCEMENTS.
SEND SOMETHING FROM THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
HAPPENING A LOT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: BUT THE REAL CRIME
IS CRITICIZING THE BILLIONAIRE.
[LAUGHS]
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
ABSOLUTELY.
I CRITICIZE HIM AND TALKED ABOUT
HIS MONEY AND THEY ACCUSE YOU OF
BEING ANTI-SEMITIC.
I AM LIKE, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HE
WAS JEWISH.
I'M TALKING ABOUT WHERE HE IS
SPENDING HIS MONEY.
IT'S N